what's going on guys so today we're
talking video game movies don't be
afraid we have a couple of experts here
to hold our hands and lead us through
this deep dark forest he's one of the
faces of Smosh games and he's been a
competitor on king of the Nerds you know
him as joven it's Joshua open Shire he
is the face of the J wits channel on
YouTube he's probably the foremost
Pokemon expert in the universe next to
Ash Ketchum
say hello to Josh Witten Keller so guys
we're gonna kick it off talking about
best and worst video game movies what is
one that you thought okay this was
pretty true to the source material
Mortal Kombat was my go-to answer and
the reason it was was because it was a
great night nice film lot of action a
lot of finance what you wanted but then
you have moments like scorpion doing his
finishing move and then sub-zero the ice
yeah so you have to take that out
because it doesn't live up to the video
game there's there's a handful liberties
but taking the knives into consideration
it was a hype movie it had a very catchy
theme song I'm also on the same page I
got them yet a pig but Mortal Kombat is
such a hit so hard for me you totally
just reminded me that theme song and you
say it's a catchy theme song I might say
the best theme song ever
Silent Hill I think did a great job
taking two games and putting into one
movie yeah that wasn't horrible I think
for me like the closest we've gone in
terms of like the budget the casting is
our Prince of Persia well it's not the
best action film of all time it's
aesthetically pleasing mm-hmm the
casting solid I thought oh yeah who's
all right you know could be a little
more Persian that's kind of an issue
with the story in general yeah that is
an issue with Hollywood in general
Princeton Persia movie was so important
because that's the Disney saying alright
if we can make this work we can do this
with other titles so principals I had to
be good it had to do well and it made
money you know is I think Tomb Raider my
way listening because Angelina Jolie
yeah and her but how hard a time did you
guys have finding a video game movie
that you could put at the top of your
list as best or a favorite the answer
really is simple what is the best of
your game movie yeah it hasn't been made
yet it's just very simple there's
there's movies that get close I don't
want to kill myself after watching it
but there's no good definitive that was
a video game movie done right you don't
have like the Citizen Kane of video game
films you don't you don't even have the
Forrest Gump of like it you don't even
have video game films like nominated for
awards so let's shift gears and just
talk about straight up abominations
that's not the hurt your soul yeah
what's one film that you had high hopes
for and just disappointed the heck out
of it just pulled the rug out from under
you you know what I with her I didn't
know who directed it before I went in to
watch the movie on the House of the Dead
there were zombies the game is simple
you see the zombie you shoot the zombie
you're great and then I saw the opening
credits you able joven yeah yeah yeah
BIA said the name on it now it's it's on
the table I'm talking the worst you get
say this man you a bowl has directed so
many terrible video game movies so not
even terrible video game movies terrible
movies begin with we're talking Ed Wood
and blow we can go through pinpoint
there's in the name of the king alone in
the dark
personal least-favorite mud rain really
bad Kings lien it - yeah a true Obama a
true blight on filmmaking so Jay what's
what's a film that really disappointed I
was a big fan of fighting you as a kid
yeah someone laid out Street Fighter the
movie seems like an innocent enough
thing you got a legit action star in
there got actually a big part of what
killed it oh you can't
oh yes I can just dig the hostages out
if I'm not dub site in 15 minutes
evacuate without me
so one film adaptation that I found to
be a crushing disappointment I know
ruined many people's entire childhoods
uh was the filmed adaptation of Super
Mario how did we not mention this Bob ha
I did not so John Leguizamo it has like
the so bad it's good fun value afterward
maybe with a few drinks in you I uh I
heard a funny anecdote from John
Leguizamo I believe that they were
mostly drunk while they were making that
movie we're doing I don't know Mary oh
just trust me I got a good feeling about
this alleyway I don't know what good
yeah so you have to be drunk to watch it
that's one of those movies that will
live on in our lifetime that luckily
hopefully on children just won't ever
remember the magic lived in a world with
an awesome Super Mario Brothers movie
it'd be so different that's the video it
came what it would have changed the
world it would have been like how we
have all the superhero movies today yeah
but like if that we do it any great that
would have opened the doors so we
wouldn't have had a crappy I Street
Fighter Mortal Kombat would have been
amazing like yeah like it could have
opened up like an age the same way Iron
Man and the Avengers have there is an
alternate dimension where that world
exists right why are we in the world we
know we're the worst yeah and then
there's a there's a Donkey Kong spin-off
at all yeah so I think we've really
established that these films are almost
across the board disappointments yeah
does it even make sense to make video
game movies I think it does uh it just
it's all in its presentation of how it's
done because you have a 50-hour game
that you're trying to put into an hour
half a movie makes it very difficult but
let's say you just
one aspect of it don't make a mass
effect movie that revolves around
Commander Shepard that's not going to
work you make a movie that's set in that
universe that has familiar characters
and names that you know and expand on
that that works out great you have to do
a spinoff I think if you try and adapt a
story directly the audience is always
going to have a weird thing with it
because you play a video game and have
the control of these characters yeah the
main character is never gonna be the
same as how you always imagined it
you'll walk into the movie and your hope
is going to be so high like there's of
course it's going to be a disappointment
and that's what's happened every single
time before we love these games we
regret we want to love this movie this
game was so amazing the movies down here
it can be done you just have to have
people that love the material and know
how to present it to an audience that
loves it more than that guys haven't
here I've learned a lot thank you so
much you for having us
of course so guys what video game would
you want to see turned into a movie
leave us an answer in the comment
section below tell us why the coolest
answer you're gonna get a screen junkies
t-shirt I want to thank my awesome
guests Joshua open Shire joven check him
out on Smosh games and Josh Shaywitz
Whitney Heller check out his YouTube
check them both out on Twitter hit me up
on Twitter I'm Hal Rudnick I want to
thank you for watching bye bye
hey screen junkies check out honest game
trailers over on Smosh games click the
bucks to check out our honest take on
Mario Kart screw you blue shells